all right welcome everybody we are in
the pre-show for the democratic debate
this evening we are entering our number
I believe we are entering our entering
our number 13 of programming today
between the broadcast show and
livestreams and we have more upcoming
tomorrow morning so thank you for
joining me we have so much to discuss
and a very very big evening where
certainly I would guess the impeachment
hearings of the last couple of days over
the last week really will be a topic
tonight I have a whole bunch of things
to discuss with you in advance of the
debate starting at the top of the hour
this is just the pre-show we will be
going over I have so many different
things to look at here we will be going
over to twitch at the top of the hour
our streams of debates on YouTube almost
always have gotten shut down on twitch
we've somehow avoided it although last
time CNN shut us down
tonight it's NBC so we will see at the
top of the hour we will start over on
twitch twitch TV slash David Pakman so
if you want to get set up if you want to
watch on corporate media by all means do
it but if you want to watch the same
debate over on independent media with
commentary from people just like you and
me then make sure you're following me at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman let me make
sure that is all working properly we
have five different screens doing many
different things here right now it does
appear to be so we will see you on
Twitch at the top of the hour but many
things to discuss let me actually get my
list it's been a very busy day today and
I I just put together the list of things
I wanted to talk about I have a variety
of medical amounts of water here and
some recreational like this one and we
will see what other medical liquids
appear later Super chats I will answer
as they come in the same person sending
three Super chats to say I'd rather
watch a podium and then a fourth Super
chat saying Bernie 2020 so thank you for
the $20 I very much appreciate that
there's this weird glitch where I can't
see the bottom super chat until another
super chat is sent so sir
Burress I'll have to wait Oh Cerberus
says yang gang love you guys okay thank
you very much so question one how much
will impeachment be a topic of
discussion tonight I think it will be a
topic I think it will present itself as
a nice opportunity maybe for Tulsi
Gabbard to separate herself from the
other candidates in what may be her last
debate of the 2020 Democratic primary we
will we will look at the polling here
actually let's look at the polling now
because going into this we have seen Joe
Biden's spike in the last poll and we've
seen Warren and Sanders drop but it's
just one poll and as you can see the
race looking very very different than it
did back in April where Joe Biden was
polling 41% Bernie at 15 and Warren at 8
where we are now is Biden at 31 Warren
at 18 and Bernie at 16.7 so listen right
now I believe that the only people that
can really justify staying in this thing
and I'm gonna be generous here okay I
could draw the line in a much more
aggressive way but I'm gonna be generous
here Biden Warren Sanders are of course
the frontrunner and they should be
staying in this thing Budaj edge clearly
has made the case and you can see here
the purple line he sort of bottomed out
around four he's doubled his support to
around eight and he's actually doing
really well in some of the early state
primaries which we will look at
momentarily Budaj
obviously should stay in and then listen
Kamala Harris at four she should stay in
maybe she can do something in a state or
two it this is insane because he just
entered but Bloomberg more than
Williamson Bullock Delaney Castro
Bennett's tire Booker Klobuchar and
Gabbard and yang he has a stronger case
than they do to stay in and then you
know it gets borderline around Andrew
Yang and Gabbard that they probably are
gonna have to go relatively soon it's
just the reality and I know a lot of
people don't don't like hearing that
let's take a look at Iowa and I should
adjust some of the things I have going
here just to make it easier
and there's some very strange noises
coming from from outside the studio
which is very very odd Iowa hmm
we may be having some kind of an alarm
situation we got a fire in the studio
folks got have clear out now I'm kidding
there is an alarm going off at the
studio weird very strange okay but I
think we're okay we're still here so
let's look at Iowa in Iowa you see Pete
Buddha judge doing extraordinarily well
he may win Iowa in New Hampshire we have
what are the latest polls Buddha judge
in the latest poll also winning in New
Hampshire although in third place
according to the two prior polls
conducted around the same time in Nevada
you have Biden 24 Warren 18 Bernie 18
Biden leading all of the polls there and
then the fourth early primary is South
Carolina whereby Biden is very very much
ahead in South Carolina so that's the
way it looks at this point in time and
we'll go back to the national polls let
me answer a couple of Super chats here
oh yeah people may not know this but
there are free super chats available if
you're a YouTube premium subscriber and
you are on mobile you can use the dollar
sign and I guess YouTube is just giving
people free super chats this was
happening all throughout the impeachment
hearings and you can just send them to
me why not write people over on twitch
asking me why I'm not there we're on
YouTube right now and we will get to
twitch at the top of the hour this is
just the pre-show at the top of the hour
I invite you to come with me over to
twitch.tv slash David Pakman we also
will be oh yes people asking about
membership carryovers up there it says
0:45 website members what the hell is
that that is websites website members
from join pakman.com the informations
there last big debate stream we had 44
website members so I just figured we
would shoot for 45 any that sign up
during the YouTube portion of the stream
will get carried over so I'll show you
how that works Maxine Moore has just
signed up for a membership just now
while we've
been talking so that gets us to one of
45 if we have one at the top of the hour
when we switch over to twitch we will
carry over with one and it would be very
unfair of me not to not to do that so
they will be carrying over okay let's
look at some of the super chats that are
going on Murphy says this guy is on fire
we're on our 13 of content today which
is which is crazy Millan davit coffe
with a $20 super chet says born e 2020
born e 2020 Cerberus asking if the
stream of the debate will be on Twitch
we're going to try it they might shut us
down who knows it's it's so hard to know
what's gonna happen
Kashif says this is my last Super chat
okay thank you
Elias Chavarria says hi I'm a high
school senior and considering options of
paying for university what are your
thoughts on income sharing agreements
and the implications I know very little
about them I'm out of the paying for
college game I've been out of it for a
while so I I would not be the right
person to advise you there James Justice
says David's chalupas are burning yeah
we had it was a we've never had a an
alarm in the studio before but we did
have one today and it was not it was a
little bit stressful I'm not gonna lie
let's see a lot of Bernie fans checking
in keep up the good content Evan Mauro
sending an any number of super chats
Magpies nest production says do you
think the main reason Biden is in the
lead is because of landlines no when you
look at most of these most of these
poles the landline bullet-pointed that
does not apply
Mario towns says hey David loved your
show keep up the good work
Ricardo Beristain says here's some dough
David thanks for all you do
who gets attacked more tonight Warren
repeat okay so let me get to the next
bullet point I am very interested
tonight in seeing
doo doo the front-runners gang up on
Pete Buddha judge because he's been
surging from behind do Bernie Warren go
at each other which we don't it doesn't
seem like that's actually to their
advantage do Bernie Warren team up
against Biden does Pete come out looking
different because he now has surged from
four to eight percent I want to watch
that I do also want to see whether
anyone is in desperation mode because
again when you look at the polling is
this national yes it is you see that
it's really Biden Warren and Sanders and
if if if Pete Buddha judge can continue
this rise that he has experienced and he
wins the first two primaries in which
he's leading Buddha judges in it I don't
think anybody else is really in this
thing Harris can at least justify
staying in but I don't know that anyone
else is really in this thing so that is
going to be interesting to see who is
even in tonight's debate let's figure
that out because I have been very tied
up with impeachment stuff that was the
fourth debate fifth debate let's see I
don't even know what's happening tonight
like what are we waiting for let's see
the fifth debate will be held on
November 20th from 9:00 to 11:00 at
Tyler Perry studios in Atlanta it will
be moderated by Rachel Maddow Andrea
Mitchell Kristen Welker and Ashley
Parker the candidates who qualified were
Biden Booker Buddha judge Gabbard Harris
Klobuchar Sanders steyr Warren and yang
so we have ten candidates on the stage
again so we will have a significant lack
of depth or a lot of people that are
basically just placeholders on the stage
and they won't be spoken to very very
much is what it seems like looking ahead
to the sixth debate oh it's the day
before I go on vacation that's gonna be
quite a day uh who has qualified there
so far only Biden Sanders Warren Buddha
judge Harris and Klobuchar only six
qualified for the next debate and indeed
if some of these other folks don't make
it I predict that their campaigns will
be relatively relatively short-lived a
welcome to the pre-show
for the debate the debate will not be
here it will be over on Twitch whoa
Elizabeth Warren popping up out of
nowhere so the the reasons are numerous
and they relate to copyright and they
relate to shutdowns of our our streams
so please follow me over at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman we will also we have
a target of 45 new website members this
evening and we are well on our way
Annie Capek is new member number two of
the evening Andrew sauce is new member
number three of the evening and Robert
O'Malley
is new member number four oh and I
almost missed Daniel tumors don't worry
Daniel I've got you that's new member
number five so we are up to five new
members any that we get over on the
YouTube portion of the evening will
absolutely carry over to twitch and then
it'll become it'll become a real party
over there I'm telling you okay let's
move now okay I do want to address
something serious there is a format
there is a a really important issue that
I want to get out of the way before we
get to the really important stuff
because I've been asked to comment on
this and I really want to be very very
clear there are questions about whether
former Democratic candidate and current
congressman Eric's wawel was engaged in
an act of public flatulence live on
television last night and I am taking a
position and I'm taking the position
we're looking at it very strongly to
quote the president and I am taking the
position that this was flatulence and it
call it what you will it's a natural
thing it happens I believe that this was
flatulence and the reason I believe it
was is that he visibly braces in advance
of it and if it's Chris Matthews mug as
we were told you just would there's no
way soir well would brace like that
let's take a look and I believe that I
will be vindicated is uncontradicted
that the president used taxpayer dollars
to ask the Ukrainians to help him
achieve exactly he actually seems to
sort of go up like that so I I mean
listen he is denying it
I guess MSNBC in some sort of bizarre
flatulate of solidarity with Erics wall
well has put out a statement copping to
Chris Matthews moved a mug but it is
just extraordinarily difficult to
believe right folks let's just give it
one more listen and and again look for
how he braces and maybe we can even play
it at half-speed yeah that's even better
let split this is becoming like there's
a pruder film you know I'm gonna go even
crazier I actually want to see it at one
quarter speed and let's see what what
happened
I think it was rather visibly went up to
inches there so III mean listen if
anybody wants to argue with me about
this I am willing to debate it but that
seems now that we've got it isolated
what does one more time the key key
moment and up he goes I think that this
is just it's a done deal it's what it
was okay let me get to some other okay
some people disagree with me let me get
to some of the super shots here
it's a crazy evening I know it Jeff yang
and Dylan Brown checking in J CDC sends
me a super check but says I want you to
do me a favor though that is language
that clearly is extort Evander Ibis
because you're giving me the money
we'll see it would be more bribers if
you said you wouldn't give me the money
unless I do the favor Murphy says if we
go in till midnight Eastern he'll send
to hunt he or she will send $200 via
super chat Stephen Robin's saying David
come on my podcast I'm not familiar with
the podcast I must say let's see who
else has something to say
hairy tail Hale der has been watching
all day yeah it's been busy how do you
do it it's just been a crazy day it's
it's been it's been literally non-stop
Leo Reyes says you're a continuous
breath of fresh air and this corporate
riddled nightmare were all under I hope
you defend yourself legally to the
fullest extent
I plan to against all claims all claims
I will defend myself legally Daniel
Krieger calls Warren an enemy of the
left oh boy mysterious future claims
Bernie has this on lock
Ryan Henry Dean believes that it was -
oh it just scrolled up it was too loud
for a fart it was a mic rub I don't I
mean listen it is weird because it is
that the one argument against this being
flagellated is that the microphone is
presumably on his lapel and
how would it be that the fart is louder
let me just take one more look use
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help them cheat it's strange but it
just it could have been that loud I
don't know
Jake Herman's saying whoops fart gate
hashtag Dylan Brown ten dollars if David
farts live right now now we're not going
to be doing that
Isaac Lewis Bolivia was a coup smells
like the CIA
Isaac Lewis again Bolivia was a coup
smells like the CIA Michael Saenz says
keep the content coming Marco's Sousa
says hello David so I can denote them in
hope Pete wins also an Argentinian in
the chat very much appreciated welcome
if you are just joining this is only the
pre-show we should change what's going
on because there excel we're off a fart
gate this is the pre-show
due to threats and prior incidents we
will not be streaming the debate on
YouTube the risk is just too high why
are people texting me they know what I'm
doing right now the risk is just too
high so we will be over on Twitch I see
people chatting on Twitch right now
saying I hope we don't get shut down and
all of this different stuff head over
there at the top of the hour we will be
at twitch.tv slash David Pakman and let
me see how things are even going over on
Twitch okay they seem to be going well I
think it will be a reasonable place for
at least to start this evening let me
say thank you to Rosa Parker and Lucas
velour who are new members numbers six
and seven tonight the target this
evening is 45 new members anybody who
signs up now before we switch over to
twitch all of the numbers will carry
over so we will start on twitch with a
very very strong number matthew Upchurch
asks do you throw it just scrolled past
you think sanguine will be donating to
Bernie's inauguration fund or the small
well be no fund wall well wall well not
small well Kingstown David Pakman show
is my favorite show the David Pakman
show
Thank You leo man Freddie says if you
slander Biden
give you the rest of my free super chats
now I'm not gonna be slandering anybody
tonight not deliberately anyway but it
is a good opportunity to remind any
YouTube premium subscribers that there
are free super chats available to you if
you are on mobile click the dollar sign
and there are free super chats available
epic fails asks does gymnasium Jordan
have a future after Trump yeah I think
he's gonna keep it together I don't
think that Trump will be the end of Jim
Jordan let's see thanks to Pauline Allen
for signing up as a YouTube member
that's different than website members
just to be clear Colt 45 caliber you can
see the reaction from sois well he
totally beefed alright that seems to be
the consensus okay things are happening
very quickly xox Oh Naoki an says Bernie
agreed Bolivia was a coup I know you
disagree no I don't disagree that
Bolivia was a coup I just think there's
a difference between a coup in which the
military takes over and a coup in which
the military pushes out the president
and then a lunatic religious nut takes
over I just think that you know the
black and white thinking about you know
it's either a or b is where the left
sometimes gets into problem by that
metric would you say bernie is being
dishonest full disclosure I believe in
the coup I think Bernie is being honest
about the way he sees it
Kuya Chow says definitely a fart the
shoulders are the dead giveaway
Pauline Allen has now upgraded her
membership from soy boy to beta
thanks Pauline NRL says I'm new to
YouTube are you two the new the new
Infowars host that's exactly right that
is exactly right Damien Garvey asks what
do lower polling candidates have to gain
from staying in the race Harris Buddha
judge yang etc name recognition
fundraising the possibility of maybe
negotiating their way into you know a
cabinet position or something like that
I don't know honey Petric signed up as a
YouTube member thanks to chris Roberts
and Shawn's story for the Super chats
Fabricio Larios says we need a few clips
in Spanish from you David by Remi Hinda
we may do that
tari says apparently yang mrs. bet oh
yeah I saw that tweet from yang saying
he misses Beto it seems to be the truth
Oh mega King boo you should debate Nick
Fuentes I think the dissident right
could be unlikely allows against the
globalist corporate Oleg are unlikely
allies maybe I am from the dissident
right all right I'm not sure who that is
honestly but I've heard of him but I
don't know who it is Jacob Paul Pakman
have you seen Erik Weinstein's attack on
you and Sam cedar yes I already
addressed that on the Monday show
Antonio Uribe more DP analysis Thank You
Tina garner signed up on YouTube grant
zurich says free money mage Elektra hey
David love your show shout out to dr.
dystopia absolutely absolutely we are if
you are just joining me this is only the
pre-show our YouTube streams of debates
have almost all gotten shut down
recently so in about five minutes we
will be switching over to twitch where
we've had a little more success but
sometimes still get shut down twitch.tv
slash David Pakman and I see people
waiting on twitch I I don't know how
they know what I'm saying but they seem
people are chatting on Twitch about what
I'm saying on YouTube we're coming we're
coming in an additional five minutes
thanks to Tammy's arrow for signing up
at join pakman.com tammy is new member
number 8 of the evening the goal is 45
every sign-up that happens before the
debate starts will transfer over to
twitch so fear not be or not
giant squid says there's no way it
wasn't a fart he stopped talking for a
split second to let it out yeah that's
my general view the paws and the
shoulders up for me tell me everything I
need to know Millan
davit cough says I apologize when the
message is scrolled down like that it's
when a bunch come in at once let me get
back up
if you slander the candidates I will pay
all your legal fees okay
xoxo now Chen says if I give all my
super chats would you say battle juice
three times into the camera no I don't
think so geez simple gee Smigiel
have you seen that skit of Donald Trump
feeling up Giuliani dressed in drag I
have seen that and it's weird but still
even despite that Trump is preparing to
say I don't even know Rudy Giuliani I
just don't know who the guy is Murphy it
is either over 50 or under 40 black
white I don't know what that means a
Jesse B says it's trans Day of
Remembrance say trans rights just a
viewer says who is your favorite
centrist Democrat I guess who Leon
Castro if it's a funny question I've
never really thought about it that way
but I guess who Leon Castro I would say
James Stephens smelly swell and the
doodoo nothing Democrats I hope that was
worth it for you retro ambassador
checking in from Iowa State University
thank you
xoxo now chan says beetlejuice okay a
bunch of these that I don't understand
David Miller listens on the job site I
appreciate that
grant Sorek is sending out more free
money azeris wants me to do nicknames
for Pete Buddha judge and it's trolled
by not gonna do that
do I think Warren's recent
medicare-for-all split plan Sanders will
go after her tonight interested in
seeing that we covered that on the
broadcast show today and I do want to
watch that I think it's possible watch
in his calling me or watch in says that
the coolest Jewish dude is Sam cedar not
me
I was just texting with Sam earlier
today josh says Pakman the best non
corporate news stream do you think yang
is being silenced on debates polls
corporate news etc I saw an MSNBC poll
where Andrew yang was polling 3% and
they had a bunch of people polling more
than him and a bunch of people polling
less than him and his name was just
missing from the screen like he's not
gonna win the nomination I recognize
that but you know neither are a whole
bunch of these people and why were they
on screen and Andrew yang was not it was
very very odd let's see Manuel Sanchez
what's up David do you think Tulsi is
gonna kneecap anyone tonight hopefully
food
I doubt it I don't thinks I think Tulsi
will mostly be a non-factor epic fails
who needs a big win tonight Bernie
Bernie because he has been as you can
see here oh wait no this is Warren so
recently Warren is down Bernie is back
up so it's since this period of time
that it's been downhill for Bernie then
about a month and a half ago Bernie
started picking it back up and more
recently they both dropped Bernie and
Warren Biden up so I think Bernie Bernie
needs a good night Bernie needs a good
night
Jessica Storm says love you great
content insomniac says it sounded like a
phone vibrating on a table I don't
believe that this is a phone vibrating
on a table crayons to help also why is
there a is he sitting on a table like it
doesn't it doesn't really make too much
sense to me let's see
Declan disart did you see or comment on
the handwritten note Trump was
photographed with this morning on
tomorrow's show
we were already kind of closed up for
today's show by the time that that
started I will talk about that tomorrow
cool vid kid will you do another show
with Kyle kolinsky any time in the
future nothing planned but always glad
to giant squid who would win in a fight
Anna and gent from TYT or Tammy Lehren
and Sean Hannity Oh Anna and Jenk would
absolutely crush them it would not even
be funny rad Willie isn't it funny how
Trump is latched on to basic humor like
swallow Elle's fart yeah they love it
they just love it
okay let me say a big thank you to
Joseph oh so do a weight I guess maybe
he doesn't want his whole name said
Joseph asorio very good a new member
number nine of the evening so this is
the pre-show not six nine this is the
debate pre-show we are going to switch
over right now to twitch follow me to
twitch twitch TV slash David Pakman
download the app if you're on mobile it
takes a minute we'll be over there into
twitch TV slash David Pakman for an
attempted debate stream if they do